>>Teacher: Guys, I know, I know.
Just take a deep breath, you guys.
Give us a few minutes, okay?
Justin, can you stop, please?
Ladies and gentlemen--
>>Narrator: Having trouble
managing your classroom?
Here are some of our
favorite Tricks of the Trade.
>>Student: I want my mamma.
>>Felipe: You want your mamma?
Why don't you go get a Kleenex,
so we can blow your nose.
Come on, let's go.
>>It's kind of like a magician.
You redirect.
You know, they're focused
on one thing,
and then you just get a Kleenex, that
was a redirection, then it's just--
they just need that little focus
to get back, and then it's over.
>>Narrator: Share one of your tricks
with fellow teachers on Edutopia.